y en directo Ahora nos vamos a estar Río
de Janeiro con nuestra corresponsal
Valeria sakoné con ella ampliaremos la
información relativa a las palabras del
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
quien hoy aseguró que la policía y los
militares colaboraron con los fanáticos
de Jair bolsonaro que atacaron el
domingo en Brasilia las sedes de los
tres poderes aseguró también que se debe
Investigar la financiación de los actos
Valeria Cuáles han sido las acusaciones
concretas del presidente
hoy el presidente Luis Ignacio Lula de
Silva ha culpado a los militares y a la
policía de abrir literalmente la fuerza
del palacio del plan acto sede de la
presidencia para permitir que los
vándalos que el domingo pasado
destrozaron todo pudiesen entrar es una
acusación muy grave y el presidente Lula
la justifica diciendo que no hay ninguna
fuerza rota y esto explicaría que
alguien dejó entrar a los manifestantes
es importante notar que Lula hizo esta
declaración durante un encuentro con los
periodistas que van a cubrir las
noticias de la presidencia una forma de
mostrar transparencia y también dijo que
va a ser una criba profunda en todo el
gobierno en toda la administración para
echar a los militares y crear un
gabinete civil
también hoy se reveló que la policía
federal halló unos documentos en la
residencia del exministro de Justicia
Anderson Torres que habrían permitido a
bolsonaro revertir el resultado de las
elecciones que se ha encontrado
exactamente en casa del ex ministro
Valeria
hoy la policía federal ha encontrado en
el domicilio de Anderson Torres el
exministro de Justicia un borrador de
decreto que sugería a Jair bolsonaro
intervenir el Tribunal Superior
electoral para prácticamente anular el
resultado de las elecciones lo que sería
inconstitucional es algo muy grave que
va a ser investigado hay que recordar
que Torres asumió el uno de enero la
secretaría de seguridad del Distrito
Federal donde se encuentra Brasilia
hecho a todas las personas responsables
del esquema de seguridad durante la
investidura de Lula y acto seguido se
marchó de vacaciones a Orlando en los
Estados Unidos en la misma ciudad donde
estaba bolsonaro es muy grave esta
acusación y por esta razón la Corte
Suprema ha dictado una orden de prisión
se prevé que mañana Torres vuelva
departamento de sus vacaciones a Brasil
para entregarse a la justicia a un Jesús
abogados han pedido a la Corte Suprema
que revisen la orden de prisión